the truth about andrew tate i want to  tell you who he is based on my personal  experiences with him i have had nothing  but positive encounters with andrew tate  he's always been very gentlemanly i  think he's very fun he's very  charismatic and he's very smart i think  he's a great businessman he's also let  me say i haven't mentioned this yet he's  also loyal he's loyal to his friends  he's loyal to his brothers and that is a  huge sign of somebody's character  there's a lot of accusations about him  online and honestly i just don't believe  them because i've met the guy and  because i don't believe them i will meet  andrew again  and we will do another podcast again